how would you deal with a man's hormones
then
how would you deal with it like so what
i mean is he's incredibly horny you're
not in the mood
this is a recurring thing how do you
deal with his hormones how would you
deal with it here's a subscription oh
sorry i said the word exactly
do you think corn has saved marriages
no
i think i think
i think
angry men doing things to women against
their will
there's actually statistics on that
where since the out
since the growth and and the
accessibility of
adult material uh it has actually
reduced or well i mean i don't know
whether it's a correlation
causation but
the the sexual assault rates have
dropped over the last 20 30 years
and proliferation of adult material has
been exponential everybody has it on
their phone everywhere now do you do you
guys think corn is cheating
no yeah
yeah i mean like
do you think do you think you're looking
for the perfect guy no not perfect i
don't see that i don't see the point of
doing it when you're married you have
someone to help with that but that's
because you're looking at it from a
woman's point of view
but men they always want to screw
different chicks
because women were programmed to want to
be with one guy where men are programmed
to want to screw screw everything that
moves
i watch this podcast where this guy was
married and he explained that he had a
problem with the fact that his wife
um was okay with him using porn
sorry i'm sorry
um was okay with him watching corn
when she was around she she couldn't
care less that he's doing that and i
think she had a low sex drive or
something well that's probably because
he was disappointed he was in fact he
was hurt by the fact that okay you're
here and you're not offended by the fact
that i'm getting mine somewhere else
well i think it's probably that she was
sexually rejecting him that's really
hard that's how he felt that's yeah so
that's why that's my perspective like
why would you do that when
you're together i'm saying it's because
they want to screw everything that moves
like even in evil in evangelical
christians 80 of the men are addicted to
corn yeah yeah so most even the
religious guys are watching it because
i mean they're human yeah and so if
they're not going to screw all their
chicks how can we be mad if they're
they're watching corn to try to avoid
that
i mean at the same time you're also
training your brain your brain is a
muscle
if this is what you're used to watching
this is just how you get yours
it's going to be difficult when you're
married okay you know you you probably
want a visual aid every time that's very
frustrating so i've heard it is a muscle
at the end of the day okay so i've heard
men
say that they keep old oh god old
pictures and videos and use that so they
don't get addicted to corn is that
cheating
i don't see the point of it when today
women dress more scantily clad you can
just take a walk yeah but they can't do
that on the street yeah they can't take
a walk no but they they can't walk down
the street
no no not doing that
lift up your skirt
i don't see the yeah i don't have i
don't see the point of having materials
like that in your house right materials
from a woman's point of view yeah but
like the men they're biologically
predispositioned to want to screw
everything that moves yeah and i totally
get that we we all have hormones and
biological drives and things like that
but at the end of the day
you know we can't let that lead us
right but don't you think in the same
way that he would have to put up with
you being different throughout the month
going back to the question maybe you'd
have to i i don't let that lead me
either i'm i'm not an animal like i'm a
person like i can feel when i'm like one
month i may be feeling maybe irritable
or brain fog or something but i try my
best not to
let that lead me because yeah well he
could try his best yeah but you just
like you'd know like i'm sure he'd
understand okay this is her time yeah
she might have brain fog and then i
understand okay he's feeling some type
of way
i just think this guy doesn't exist
i don't know it's communication
through things i know but i think this
is why honestly a lot of like pretty
girls are single in the churches because
they are looking for this religious guy
that doesn't exist in the west in the
west i just wanted to highlight the
paradox here where
the ladies say well i or at least
certainly there was a lot of hesitation
about i can't cater to his hormones
anytime he wants because whatever mood i
might be in and yet at the same time
he's not allowed to even crack one out
to anything he literally has to be a
celibate when i tell him he can release
the beast and to be honest with you you
guys have to realize
it's a
mind
sort of
uh what's a scrambling thing to have as
a man to have your entire life
especially when you're young
dominated by this animal beast inside
your head going do it do it do it do it
get it get it get it it's constant can i
give you can i give you this example
it's personal experience um i was i was
working in france for a few months
recently
and there was a point where i was go i
was considered considering practice
practicing abstinence
right
and
in that i was okay when i was walking
about and everything i was like okay you
know because it was summer so yeah you
know a lot of girls wear kind of scanty
stuff
and i was like okay i'm not gonna look
you know like because i'm like oh if i'm
gonna try and practice this i need to
try and work in this way right
it took more energy
not to look
than to just have a glance
as in like literally a girl will pass
i'm like don't look don't know that okay
great another one don't look no no okay
great like it was by the time i'd gone
to the gym and come back
it was incredibly exhausting now that
doesn't mean you have to look in a
creepy way you can be like oh wow she's
a beautiful woman and you can just
appreciate the beauty that she's giving
for that day do you know what i mean
but there is something very primal in
men men are very visual creatures
and from that experience it was kind of
like wow it actually was harder not to
look like if a guy walked in this room
bullet naked
and i'm like looking at you it would be
hard not to look at his junk
it would take energy not to look that
exact feeling is what it's like for guys
for
especially nowadays because you know
like you said like you know like women
wear more stuff that's more tight and
you know most everything's so sexualized
now damn near be naked at the beach
so it's like it's it's like
and real talk like it was i almost start
to i almost kind of resented being a man
for it because i was like wow like it's
such an innate thing
that is so difficult to
not just not to control but to contend
with
but it is just a real fact of being a
man
quick question what does
abstinence
consist of where you don't
do you're not sexual at all so you're
not allowed to look at women no fab well
it's not that you can't look at women
but it was like if you if a guy if
you're looking at attractive woman nine
times out of ten the first thing you
think about within the first 10 seconds
is what would it be like to have sex
with her
really is that really how what you don't
think yeah 100 percent
straight up why do you think like
manchester united